what is the worst thing about it I think
the worst thing about Bernie Sanders and
as a native New Yorker myself his thick
Brooklyn accent really because it makes
him so easy to caricature uh-huh and it
means that the first time there's a
Saturday Night Live sketch they're gonna
feature someone playing a doddering old
man with a thick New York accent their
crazy hair the crazy hair and then
that's gonna be that's gonna be the one
image of you so you know for his sake
you know his dignity and you want a guy
who's this you know who's this
accomplished in the public in the public
sphere little done things for the right
reasons and wants money out of politics
and you know income inequality which i
think is pretty much what the other
thing right is whatever you ever even
when you think on the sea this guy is
passionate principled the type of person
you want in public office and you know
the comedians are not going to be kind
they're not gonna be kind and so this is
a little bit like what you were saying
about you have that the good thing about
him and the bad thing are almost the
same thing because you're saying the
good thing is 78 years old doesn't care
about a lot but you're saying the bad
thing is this accent sort of like he's
old-school and that will be easily
mocked
so it really is and he's old yeah I mean
he's old he looks old and he's old
school and he has has a very thick
Brooklyn accent you know a mana from
heaven for comedians yeah easily
mockable and the debates or you know I
mean you did it's it they're gonna be
funny yeah they are gonna be funny I'm
looking forward to some funny debate
anyway what do you think Bernie Sanders
to Brooklyn II I was born in Brooklyn I
don't like that let us know in the
comments right